one of the protesters was carried off
the field by England wicketkeeper Johnny
bairstow the match was about to begin
with Australia batting and England
bowling when The Intruders came on and
threw orange paint across the Wicket in
a statement the chief executive of
Malden Cricket Club guy lavender said
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms today's pitch incursion and with
the behavior of the protesters involved
their actions not only endanger
themselves and those who work at the
ground but they have consistently shown
complete disregard for the people who
pay to attend events not just here at
Lords but around the country at other
sporting venues
well a sport correspondent Rob Harris
sent this update
being played Johnny bestow intervened
himself carried off one of the
protesters as they launched that orange
powder on the field here at Lords there
we just had the first over of the second
ashes test with their Australia batting
England bowling and it was the latest in
what we've seen a series of similar
process at sporting events in recent uh
weeks and months we had orange power to
thrown on the table at the world snooker
championships in April then on the pitch
that said the rugby Premiership final at
Twickenham last month are now today on
the first day of the second test and
there was Swift intervention as I say
with Johnny bestow himself leading to
block one of the protesters but he had
actually had time to unleash the orange
powder on the pitch at the same time
another protest was also uh dispersed in
the orange powder on the pit as
Stewart's intervene and then there was a
clear up operation underway that was
actually dealt with fairly quickly
before clay could resume I was also the
latest in a series of the climate
protest by the just up oil campaign and
it has been a concern for various sports
event organizers but so difficult job
for the stewards to actually be able to
prevent them getting onto the pit and
they're actually cheers as the
protesters were apprehended and then
they were able to actually swiftly
resume the play I mean we have heard
obviously other sporting events where
they have been protests like at the
horse racing about the dangers it poses
here obviously less so with the more
genteel surroundings but certainly those
who've come to their day of cricket
seeing the disruption and obviously
they'll be discussing here you'd imagine
to ensure there aren't prevent uh
repeated protests too but certainly yeah
the scenes are something we have
actually been anticipating across the
sporting summer particularly from just
stop oil protesters we've had Animal
Welfare activists as well
um at horse racing but certainly
um it has been something that they have
been trying to keep a watch on we've
heard yesterday from the organizers of
the British Grand Prix at Silverstone
which will be next month in terms of
warning protests there against trying to
intervene on the most racing circuit
whether these are greater dangers but
this the latest in a series of protests
which of course a climate protesters say
is necessary to put pressure on the
government themselves
well in the last few minutes we've had
word from the prime minister's official
spokesman who's commented on this uh
saying these sorts of selfish Guerrilla
tactics are why we've introduced new
measures the PM thanks security measures
and the Swift hands of Barstow bestow uh
there's a reason we empowered police to
take action they say so the Prime
Minister thanking security and Johnny
bairstow for their action on this